this is jonco podcast number 265 with
echo charles and me
jocko willink good evening echo good
evening and also joining us tonight is
dave burke good evening dave
good evening so last podcast we
introduced marine corps doctrinal
publication one tac four which is called
competing and of course we only made it
one chapter deep
because well there's a lot to go into
and so we're gonna continue on
but first we're gonna take a little
tangential trip into my head a little
bit
so in reading that manual and as i
talked
and i talked about this i started
correlating competing
with influencing and you take that one
step further which isn't very
a very big step what is influencing
influencing is leading that's what
you're doing
so one of the main things
that i liked about this marine corps
concept of competing was this idea of
this continuum of competition that they
present
in this book that goes from pure peace
on one side just pure peace
and then it starts to move to the right
it goes to economic competition and then
classic diplomacy and then political
warfare and then there's this gray zone
and you get into hybrid
hybrid war and then you get into the
threat of violence and then you finally
cross the what they call the violence
threshold
and then so you're now you're using
violence and then even violence has
a place that that expands
on this continuum it goes to
from conventional war and then it keeps
going further and further to the right
to get to total war where one side is
using
any and all means necessary to
completely destroy their enemy
and and so with that
i started thinking about the
continuum of influence or the continuum
of leadership that we have to use
every day to lead and influence people
and and it draws some very interesting
parallels
to the continuum of competition that the
marine corps talks about and there's one
specific mark in there that really
showed a lot of similarities to me so if
we look at this continuum from the
beginning
like on the far side you have someone
that you don't care about
you don't care what they're doing you're
not trying to influence them
you don't want them to do anything at
all you just don't care that's they're
off they're like
off the spectrum i guess they're
touching it but they're not on it yet so
we don't have to worry about them
we don't care what they're doing at all
now
as soon as you cross that first little
threshold well now you've got
someone that you want to influence
you want them to follow a plan or you
want them to execute an action or you
want them to
execute a behavior so now we're on to
the continuum
of influence or the continuum of
leadership so what does it start with
well it starts we're trying to build a
relationship with that person that's
that's where we're going to begin and
what's interesting what's the best way
to start building a relationship with
someone oh you let them start to
influence you
so as soon as you're saying oh hey
that's a good i like that i like what
you're doing
and you know there's that you've heard
of this thing mirroring have you heard
this
yeah so mirroring is the physical oh if
dave's
sitting with his hand on his on his
cheek then i do the same thing and it's
a little
indicator i'm allowing you to see that
you're kind of influencing me and it's a
positive thing so that's
that's the base thing right there a
physical
actual mimicry of what you're doing
mirroring what you're doing and that's
my first way of showing you that i'm
allowing a little influence so now let's
start to build a good
a good uh rapport between us so that's
that's
you know like the lowest level and then
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna listen to
what you have to say and so i'm
starting to build this relationship and
people don't think this way people
people miss this right people don't
understand that when i
mirror you and when i listen to you i'm
actually starting to gain influence
people totally miss that all the time
they completely missed that but that's
level one right it's
it's a it's an incredibly important
level but it's level
whatever point zero eight or whatever
that number is
so so we're just listening we're letting
them model where
we're mirroring their behavior a little
bit eventually as we start to escalate
we start to model our behavior for them
a little bit we start acting a certain
way we're not asking you to do it we're
just doing it
and we're hoping that that influence
rubs off on the other person and now
they start to
they start to do the same thing and and
this is another thing that you can do
you do it subconsciously maybe do it
consciously but
you know people are in a line at a
grocery store
and a new line opens up
and if no one sees it if you just
if no one sees it you can just walk over
to that line and then people see it and
they kind of model your behavior and
you're kind of influencing a bunch of
people that you don't even know
but it's just a way of of of modeling
behavior and setting
this what we hear all the time right set
the example set a good example that's a
good way to lead
for sure that's that's that's
outstanding
eventually though maybe that's not
enough right
maybe we're trying to maybe we're trying
to influence
someone to do something either
follow a plan adjust their behavior
um take a certain action
if we're trying to get someone to do
that and we haven't they haven't really
followed our modeling now we got to
start escalating
and going a little bit harder so what's
a little bit harder
well asking good questions asking ernest
questions
oh hey hey dave why do you do this like
that and it's just a way
and then listen so that as dave explains
to me
why he's doing something a certain way
maybe it reveals to him
because now he's looking at it from a
detached perspective that's an amazing
thing about asking someone a question
when you ask someone a question it
detaches them
from what they're doing that's what
makes it such a powerful tool
because when dave is just sitting there
with his pen and he's fiddling with his
pen he's not even noticing that he's
doing it which he's literally doing
right now but as soon as i say hey if i
didn't want him to do that if it was
blurring the camera or something hey why
are you why do you keep
fiddling with that pen he has to detach
to actually figure out why he's doing it
which is a great thing because we always
want people to detach and see things
from the outside
so just asking an earnest question is a
really good
escalation on this continuum that we're
going through
now that little
question and answer session that we're
having kind of leads to a discussion
where we're actually having a discussion
well you know
sometimes i just like to fidget it makes
me think oh that's interesting you know
so we can have a we can have an actual
conversation
and that whole discussion that we're
having if i'm if i'm
utilizing this correctly i'm guiding
you i'm guiding dave in this case i'm
guiding dave
to discover
what i'm trying i want you to discover
the fact that hey if you're fidgeting
with that pen
people aren't even paying attention to
what you're saying and it's making noise
on camera
so it's like i won't but i want you to
discover those things and i want you to
actually tell me about them because then
it comes from you and then that's
infinitely more powerful
so but but sometimes it doesn't work and
sometimes even though someone detaches
they just don't they can't get far
enough
away from that thing so where does it go
from there well now i'm gonna
maybe offer an indirect little statement
about what's going on
you know just a little you know do you
think
do you think it's um distracting when
you do that if someone's watching you
i have you know i've always found that
distracting
if someone's talking to me but they're
fidgeting you know so now i'm just
i'm going a little it's indirect but it
still is i'm starting to put a little
bit more pressure
with that statement and of course now
what am i going to listen to what you
have to say
and so where does it escalate from there
now dave's still not still not paying
attention to him he's still just sitting
there fidgeting with the pen and it's
distracting to everyone it's making
noise on the
it's messing up the focus the cameras
all kinds of problems
but dave doesn't care or whatever he
hasn't he hasn't seen it yet
so then maybe we escalate a little bit
more and now
you know it's my my metaphor is about to
lose a little bit of traction because
that's such a minor thing that this next
step
it well to say hey why don't we make a
pro like a pro and con
list about fidgeting your pen right now
if we were talking about
you know going into a new market area
with a business and you were like hey
we're going we're going and i had
tried to influence you and i tried to
ask you questions about it and i
couldn't get you there
then my next escalation might be hey why
don't we do a pros and cons on
on that i'm still not coming at you i'm
just asking
asking like hey why don't we do some
pros and cons that way once again what
am i doing you're going to have to
detach to a pros and cons that's one of
the benefits of doing a pros and cons
list is it detaches you
takes some of those emotions away and
now we're sitting here
saying okay dave is detached to say well
these are some positive things it helps
me think
it gives me something to do with my
hands or let's go to the market area hey
here's the positive things about the
market area we don't have any stores
there
um there seems to be a decent market
here's the cons it's gonna
that's high rents in that area whatever
so now you can start to reveal
you reveal instead of me revealing you
hey man the rents over there ridiculous
instead of me revealing that to you
which offends you
in general it offends people to just
tell them anything
it's much better when you tell me now
all of a sudden it's your idea and this
is a beautiful thing
so that's like sort of the next thing so
another little level of escalation that
you could do on this continuum
where i'm moving in that direction i'm
still trying to
indirectly influence you
and maybe the next thing i do is offer
some kind of a bargain
some kind of a negotiation where i say
hey you know
maybe now's not the right time to go in
that market area maybe we look at it
next quarter right so it's a little
negotiation
to try and see if if if i can get you to
think a little bit more about it
it's just a negotiation
and look maybe you go yeah yeah because
maybe you saw just enough maybe you saw
maybe it just revealed just enough of
the problems that you're going yeah you
know what maybe we do
you know do this maybe maybe we went
with the next quarter yeah yeah we can
do that
and there's another little technique
that's going on there too which is i'm
giving you an out
right yeah we'll wait till next yeah
that's probably a good idea right so you
are sort of you start to see some of
those issues but you don't want to
concede
that your idea was not good so instead
you just can see that it
will just push it off a little bit but
it's still a good idea so that way your
ego remains intact and it's all
good but maybe you didn't catch that
so now we're gonna start to brush up
against
we're starting to brush up against me
being just direct with you
which is revealing some shortfalls like
just saying to you hey you know the
rents in that area are really high and
by the way
two similar businesses went into that
market
and both of them washed out and that
happened in the last 18 months
those are real concerns
and even when i do that so now i'm
showing you like those are no longer
things that you revealed those are now
things that i'm telling you
so this is a this is a transition and
and and i'm sure you're tracking this
but this whole thing is
interlaced with leadership capital this
whole thing is interlaced so
the other ones when you when i allow you
to reveal something to me my leadership
capital goes up
when i tell you something my leadership
takes a little it takes a little bit of
it
not nothing crazy but we're not neutral
right some of those in the middle might
be neutral
so i'm still going to give you an out
you know when i say hey you know the
other two other companies have gone in
their last 18 months and
so maybe we should and i give you some
timing out you know maybe we wait
another year and i give you some kind of
an out where you go yeah you know that's
probably a good idea
so we're still we still have a
possibility that you kind of see
what a good move is and you're kind of
on board with what i'm saying which is
what i'm trying to do this whole time
i'm trying to influence you right
trying to lead you trying to influence
you
then it's just straight up i'm just
going to tell you what the shortfalls
are
and if that doesn't happen you know
offer them another option what's another
option
to their plan what's another option to
their behavior
you know hey maybe putting stores
directly in that neighborhood how about
this one that's you know
four miles to the north so so yeah you
know that's also a good neighbor so i
give you an
out i give you an option that still kind
of gratifies your
ego and your idea but at the same time
it moves you in a little bit of a
direction
where i want to go so we're still doing
all right
and then the the kind of the final sort
of indirect way
is you know hey dave
why don't we put one in this market area
over here
now and then next time we'll put one in
this marketer that you want to go into
so again a lot of these are just kind of
bargaining and
kind of repetitive but they're all
different
levels of bargaining from hey we do this
later to hey we will do this
or we hold off there's a bunch of
different ways to bargain through it
and then eventually so so now you go
through these methods
these attempts to discuss something or
to to influence someone and
every one of these attempts is an
indirect attempt
every one of these attempts is me trying
to get you
to kind of come on board with what i'm
saying without
by your own by your own volition right
it's your choice that you say yeah you
know what we should do this later or
yeah you know what that
our market area to the north is good so
all those are your choice
every one of these i'm giving you to you
every one of these
attempts but we might fail even with all
those attempts
and then at some point you know
so in the marine corps what they do is
they go through this whole continuum and
then they get
eventually to this point where they
cross the threshold of violence
so what does that look like in influence
what does that look like in leadership
it's the threshold of going from
indirect to
direct and now i am absolutely
it's going to cost me leadership capital
at this time i'm now it's now going to
cost me leadership capital
which hey look there's times we have
leadership capital in the bank and if
i've been working with dave for five
years and we've done a bunch of stuff
and it's all gone great
and he's risen up through the company
and all of a sudden i i gotta call in
some chips and say hey man you know what
we're not doing that
and he goes got it you know that i'm not
saying it doesn't cost me something but
i can afford it
but when you cross the threshold of from
indirect to direct
now sudden it's definitely going to cost
you like i said you might have money in
the bank but you might have leadership
cap in the bank but it's gonna cost you
so now now is when we're saying hey you
know what
we're gonna have to we cannot go into
that market area
again this is the most gentle way to do
it it's we you know it's
it's it's us it's our team i'm on your
side
you know we we can't go into that market
area right now
and you know then the response could
still be you know if dave's
if dave's my subordinate and dave start
you know he most people get hey
we can't go into most people get the
hint and by the way we'll get to this
the the number of times that i make it
in across the threshold of direct
is so so minuscule
i can't remember times
so most people by the same say look we
cannot do that we cannot go to that
market or they go
um jacqueline's got a pretty good oh
yeah and they they feel a little bit of
it they feel that direct and they
immediately say okay i got it i see
where i see where we're going with this
it's not happening of course sometimes
doesn't work right and sometimes you say
no
this this is what we are doing
we are not going in there and it can
even escalate to no dave
you cannot open up another store that
now this is direct
right this is it i'm ordering you
because i'm the boss i'm ordering you we
will not go into that market area
we are not going to build a store there
and then you will not do that so this is
a direct thing it's not not even me
anymore it's not even us it's you
and then what so what happens after that
what happens after that is now you now
you now you have to have a stick
right out comes this because we we we
had the carrot out for a while
and some of those bargainings can be
carrots hey dave you know if you can
hold off on that
marketer i'll give you this other
marketer over here that's a carrot i use
that carrot i didn't mention it but yeah
that's another indirect way
if i can draw you away from this bad
area to this other area with a carrot
that's positive we just got a bunch of
intel that this other market area is
really starting to ramp up
why don't you put something there all of
a sudden you go oh yeah okay i didn't
know that cool you
jump on that carrot well now when you
don't when you go through this
escalation
now at some point i have to get out a
stick
and say if you try and open up something
in that market area
i'm actually gonna remove you from that
position or i'm gonna
dock your pay or whatever the whatever
the punishment becomes i'll write you up
whatever it's gonna become and that's
sort of where we get to
you know theoretically in the business
world of the highest level of
escalation is like i'm gonna fire you
right hey if you don't do what i'm
telling you to do
you are going to get fired i'm going to
fire you and of course you go outside
the business world you go into the
into the streets as they say well
there's the there's the
threat of violence comes next which is
hey you either get
you either move your car out of my
parking space or i'm going to punch you
in the head
that's a threat of violence and what
happens after that violence
i grab you i put you back in your car
and i just you know
say you better back out of this thing
right now
and and if you really want to take this
to the next level
the ultimate is the the the existential
threat
which is if you don't do what i'm
telling you to do i'm gonna kill you
right so so and it's important to it's
important to understand
what that that's there and i'll tell you
why
because a lot of people they want to
start
they want to start this this continuum
at the threat that's where they begin
that's where they begin with their
employees they start with
this is what you're gonna do that's
where they start
and once once you once you cross it
here's the thing
so once you cross that threshold of
direct or overt that's another good word
over leadership meaning i'm telling you
exactly this is totally overt there's no
there's no influence happening there
it's just me telling you what's gonna
happen
and when we do that when we when you
start out there you just don't have
anywhere to go
you don't have anywhere else to go so
the lower you are on the continuum
the better off you are as a leader
and in fact in fact if you go negative
if i go if i'm your boss dave and i go
negative and i actually let you
influence me and i say you know what
dave that looks like a great market here
i didn't even think of going in there
let's let's do it my i'm gaining more
even more leadership capital so it's
even better
if i'm in the negative if i'm if i'm in
that other chart where you're actually
influencing me
so if we can do that then we don't ever
have to get to that threshold
and i like i said i i the amount of
times i've crossed that threshold
in my life from a leadership perspective
is freaking tiny and i'll tell you where
let's just throw
one one place that happens all times it
happens with kids all the time right
with kids all the time it's it's
clean your room why because i said so
there you go yep you just went right to
the hey
direct overt i'm gonna order you what to
do
horrible thing to do what happens with
employees
happens up and down the chain of command
and here's what's interesting
when you are you when you cross
the threshold of direct and you cross
the threshold of overt
you there's a there's a
equal and opposite reaction
right so every time you bark at someone
they're they might do what you said but
there is an equal and opposite reaction
that they are looking for you to fail
they're looking to sabotage they're
looking to cause problems
the stronger the orders the more you
yell at somebody the stronger that
backlash is going to be
that's the reality of the situation
and a lot of people a lot of people need
to think about this
so in the same way that the marine corps
put together this manual
to let everybody know
that there's that they're competing all
the time you should also know that
there's a continuum that
you're on a continuum of competition all
the time and there's also a continuum of
leadership
and by the way it's up and down the
chain of command too and i didn't i'm
not going to like dig deep into this
right now
we'll do it later but when you talk
about up the chain of command
there's a continuum as well it starts
off with just compliance right
dave tells me to do something he's my
boss cool i do it
what's the next level i question what
he's saying hey dave why are we doing
that
what's the next level hey dave i don't
think we should do that we get some
resistance going then we get to
objection
this is a bad idea and then we
eventually get to refusal
and then we get to mutiny so there's a
continuum there as well
and there's some people that start off
you know if they don't have a
if they're not thinking strategically
they go right to this this doesn't make
any sense that's where that's where they
go right too
they're jumping right there and now all
of a sudden what are they going to get
back an equal and opposite reaction
which says shut up and do what i told
you to do
so we don't want to go to war we want to
build relationships
we want to build relationships with
other countries we other nation states
we want to have relations we don't want
to go to war
war costs us money and lives
we don't want that we don't want to go
to war with our employees
we don't want to go to war with our
teammates
if you recognize this continuum you can
start to say oh
i see what's going on i'm escalating how
much am i going to escalate what's the
next
lowest minimum step i could take in my
escalation
so that's what we need to do we need to
pay attention to that
i don't have to do this i can barely
think of times when i've had to do this
and wise because i listen up what other
people have to say i dig in i mean i
said don't dig in
to my position i don't think my position
is infinitely better than yours i think
probably if you and i both wanna
kill bad guys and win the war our ideas
are gonna be pretty close
i think if we both wanna take care of
our clients and
and make profit our ideas are gonna be
pretty close they're gonna be pretty
close
close enough that i can be fairly
agreeable with whatever it is
someone else wants to do
but it's a continuum that we have to pay
attention to
just like competing what do you got dave
you're over there taking notes
i was i was just thinking i mean i'm
listening to what you're saying and i'm
making the connection and you're using
you're using examples that i actually
get to live
i lived in the military but i get to
live that now too because i have
relationships with the clients we work
with i have relationships inside of
on front i have relationships at
different in different ways
even with you and there are times that
you and i are working together
there are times that you're helping me
almost in a support role with a client
and there's times that
you're the ceo of the company i'm
running one of the departments
as you're talking about that i'm
picturing this this continuum and like
okay where's the threat of violence
where does physical violence where does
war
come in the more you make deposits or
the more
the more you take the indirect approach
the more you get to keep doing that
and the more you go to the direct
thread the more you have to use that
and just the idea of the recognition is
that and i'm just thinking of those
terms of
the more indirect you are the more
leadership deposits i make
the more that's the technique i get to
use because
the more i let you influence me the more
likely you're going to be doing the
things you want to do that help us get
to the inside and i never have to
i never have to move down that i almost
never have to move down that continuum
i'm trying to think of a time where
i'm trying to think of a time where you
had to escalate in a way that i
recognized
and i i've been working four years
now i'm not saying that that hasn't
happened i'm not saying that the
escalation hasn't occurred but it's
i can't think of a time where i went oh
damn i kind of i kind of pushed him
up the stair step so it has been subtle
enough
the times however many times has
happened but the reason it works
even though subtle escalations the
reason they work is because that's the
technique you always use
so so the idea of the threat of violence
especially if that's your first move
it's so limiting it gives you so few
options
after that that it's such a bad
it's not a bad first move it's even a
bad sixth or seventh month i think
there's this idea that there are so many
things
and i think the part of that as a leader
is that i want to avoid war as well even
if i'm the boss even if i'm in charge
that's not what i want
and i think the way you close it was
because the equal and opposite reaction
and the satisfaction of knowing your way
you're going to win
is not should not be enough to to make
and i as a parent makes the most sense i
know i'm going to win that war with my
kid
if i tell my kid to clean his room
because i said so he is going to clean
his room
yep what a great victory yeah
and and yeah for how long until the
reaction from him becomes so big and so
violent that i lose
all influence over him yeah the
the other thing is as i brush up against
um hey well maybe it's the time maybe
it's the time to go direct
in this situation most of the time i
have to weigh that against
okay well what does that get me
strategically right where does that get
me strategically
if i've got to say you know what dave
this you need to you need to
do it this way from now on i want you to
use this font on
the powerpoints right whatever thing you
want to
come up with where does that get me
strategically all you have to do is take
one step back and say wait a second
where does that get me strategically
does that improve my relationship with
dave does this make him want to
do a better job does this like it you
just have to take one step back and you
go oh yeah this is dumb
this is a dumb move what i should do is
is
be a better influencer have a better
relationship explain myself better
do some bargaining talk about it maybe
i'm wrong
maybe the font that he's using is
actually better for these and
and and by the way has he picked a font
that's illegible
right has he picked a font that's
illegible is it
is it cyrillic is that the right word i
don't know
cyrillic is that the right word like the
russian russian yeah is it izzy
picks a font that is illegible in
english right
and then then i kind of have to make a
stand but if it's legible
if people can read it why am i freaking
out the answer is i'm stupid
i want to waste my leadership capital on
something that doesn't matter
but by the way up and down the chain of
command because if i said hey dave
what do you think of that font you know
what you'd say to me you're like well
i've been using it but what does it not
look good and i'd say well i don't know
it's a little bit unclear from a
distance
you'd say oh i'm going to fall on my
sword about this spot
no you'd actually say oh well which one
have you been using and i'd say oh i've
been using ariel
because it has sharp edges which i like
and you say
oh click down drop drop the menu there's
ariel you click on it yeah you're right
that does
look pretty good jocko and i go gee
thank you
and you say you know what i'm going to
change all my briefs to ariel
because just vice versa i'm not sitting
here telling you
use cyrillic fonts that can't be read by
by english speaking humans so
you're so what do we do i'm
i'm offering a little suggestion and
you're going oh yeah that's a great
suggestion
my leadership capital went up your
leadership capital went up it's a
beautiful thing
or we can have world war seven about a
font
it's such a tactical loss
for you to say it's first of all to
tackle a loss from you say you need to
change this font
this you need to use arial because
that's what i use
yeah okay great oh hey by the way it's
different
that font's different on other systems
and now it looks like just a horrible
thing
if you're smart you go hey oh you like
ariel cool
got it we're moving forward
be surprised be surprised
all right it's interesting isn't it
it's interesting how you kind of use the
pen
fidgeting example on dave over here but
you literally did me like that
did i really yeah we have it remember i
was clicking the pen
long time ago yeah yeah yeah it was on
online
oh you need to post it there and you
would i i did post it
i know what i said i said do you think
the mic picks up that noise
yeah do you think that likes and you
know what you said
you said no i don't think so but you
didn't dig in
no but then you kind of clicked it a
couple times while we were just quiet
and you know what you heard click click
click click click click click and then i
laughed
yeah and i did it it was weird it kind
of was it was almost like in
not slow motion but kind of like i could
slowly
within the span of i would say maybe six
seconds
i slowly picked up on what you're doing
there like why you said it like that
like you're saying hey stop doing the
clicking just stop clicking
that's what you're saying and but you
said it in this way hey do you think
that that that's going to happen and the
way the tone everything like you could
tell you knew what you were doing with
the way you delivered that question
here's the here's the no kidding
the the no kidding when i asked you that
question i was earnestly asking that
question like
do you think that's going to show up now
it's an earnest question
do you think that clicking is going to
show up on this podcast
it's an earnest question i probably had
a pretty good suspension because i can
freaking hear it through my headphones
for
15 minutes but you got to detach from
those emotions
and you got to ask her in this question
because maybe if it's not going to show
up why am i worried about it
i'm not going to let it i'm not going to
let it bother me if it's not going to
show up
it's not going to be on the audio then
who cares
i'm not going to care about that if you
want to click your pen all day cool it's
not bothering me it's not going to be on
that
we're good so it's an earnest question
but i mean it's it's we did know the
answer yeah kind of because we can hear
it you know it's kind
of interesting we'll see because you
know i did
kind of say no i don't think so or i
forget exactly what i said get the
replay
yeah but i feel like if i remember
correctly i was kind of
at least at the very least implied that
like no no it's all good
almost for just for a split second
though
the thing is that was a version of me
like defensively
i was about to say that wasn't really
that was uh instinctual defense
instinctual
exactly like that instinctual defense
yeah yeah
and then but i was so it was so not like
just natural
yeah but it was so not called for like
on a
like a primal level if you will like it
was so not helpful that i felt that it
was so not called for and i don't i
don't have to dig in on this
click in the pen let's face it like i
know that it's like a habit you know
i mean clicking pens to have it and then
what made it additionally interesting
just a little teeny tiny interaction was
that
i was like oh man i do it like out of
habit right there's the excuses like
trying to explain like oh i know how to
have it and then instead of you saying
there's no excuse or whatever you were
just like oh and then you grabbed like
the nearest non-clicking pin and just
simply gave you
bargaining with options
that was the carrot right the carrot
like oh maybe
deviate your attention from that yeah
there you go
affect it you know the things that fall
into the category of
indirect and direct like the techniques
you can use can actually
i was thinking about that conversation
can actually change
if early in a relationship or
relationship that doesn't have a lot of
mutual respect or you don't have
any of that leadership capital built you
can say uh hey dave don't don't click
your pen
and i'd be like okay i'll probably
comply but in my mind like dude
what's the deal and i might i might have
that natural that little reaction that
little ego hit and then
that little resistance or even maybe a
little resentment whatever it is and
this is a small example but
it would fit in the category of direct i
don't
naturally like that but over time if
you've actually done the things you were
just talking about and you've ex you've
built
enough capital what falls as indirect or
influenced that actually can expand you
can say to me right now
hey don't click that pen and i'm going
to have no reaction to it
because i'm going to think oh he's only
telling me that for my own benefit for
the benefit like
i'm not going to have that rash so that
that what appears to be a direct
that you're saying something directly to
me i don't even register that as a
director that actually fits in
in the category of at a minimum there's
no withdrawal there so even the things
that you do
as little as they are the options for
indirect
leadership actually can grow things that
would normally be outside there
where i would have some sort of problem
with you saying that
we're at i think uh muster three and you
go hey
when you're doing q a you
say i think you said something like you
say uh in between don't do that anymore
and the way you said it didn't bother me
at all but it could be that if you have
that conversation with somebody
and you don't have any leadership
capital buildup they might not like that
so you being able to say that to me is a
function of
the trust that we have the the influence
that that we've shared and and
the amount of leadership capital you
have that you can actually kind of be
direct
and it doesn't bother me that it would
in a way that it would i just comment
you know day one like i don't like the
way you talk
do it differently and i'm not gonna like
that no matter who i am so
even what you can do what you can get
away with in a sense of what is still a
leadership
capital deposit that will grow as well
yeah that that's that's why it's all
interlaced with leadership capital
because if you start off day one by
saying i don't like the way you talk
that's you you just went into a deficit
immediately yeah and now you've got to
dig your way out of that
that's why it's totally interlaced with
leadership capital because the more
leadership capital you have
the more when you need to now if i said
hey dave you're saying uh when you talk
and hey dave
this answer was bad and hey dave the way
you presented this your slides were all
they didn't look good and hey and i just
started everything was negative
well i'm eventually going to run out of
leadership capital and start going in a
bad way
and your your attitude is all jocho does
is just tell me what i do wrong
and i guess i can't do anything right
and i guess i just don't even need to be
here and i just go look for another job
it just get you know because i i've
expended all my leadership capital
so it's completely intertwined with
leadership capital completely
intertwined with leadership capital
but just like people you know i said
this on ef online the other day
i people usually think they have more
leadership capital than they do
they they usually think they're just
rolling deep in
in in leadership capital in their own
little
heads they think of course
so i always kind of treat every
situation
as if okay you know i i'm i'm lean i'm
running lean it's gonna be lean
christmas
as my parents used to tell me gonna be
lean christmas
so i always think i don't have
leadership capital to spare because also
what if i really need leadership capital
tomorrow what if tomorrow i go hey dave
i know it's your your anniversary your
10-year anniversary your 20-year
anniversary or whatever
and i know that you're supposed to go to
uh the mountains with your wife
for three days and we just had a client
call and you now have to go to
oklahoma to talk to them and that i
might have to do that tomorrow
and that's the way it is so am i really
how much how how
where do i want that account right i
want that account to be as built up as i
possibly can so that means i'm not going
to waste
leadership capital on little things that
don't matter not gonna happen
yeah that's why the default no matter
where you are should almost always be
almost always be on that side of there
the default should be on that side of
the spectrum
yeah and it's weird too because you have
the you have the threshold of violence
we have the the on the continuum
on the war continuum on the com on the
competing continuum there's a threshold
of violence
there's actual real violence with with
influencing people like you have to
admit that that you can push people
around and you can
smack them and you can beat them up like
that's a there's a there's a threshold
of violence
on the on the influence on the influence
continuum
before that there's there's a one
between direct and indirect
so you cross that one which is a which
is a huge one that's like the big one
yeah now of course
i guess the threshold of violence is a
big one too on influence because now
you're getting charged with
assault or murder
or murder depending on what level of
violence you took it to
so it's important to think about these
things
and with that we're going to jump into
this this
this whole thing man i mean i just like
have just been thinking about this
non-stop
which is pretty normal for me to think
about these things non-stop
so competing we're u.s marine corps
brand new manual one tac four
it's called competing last uh last time
we covered chapter one this time we're
covering chapter two this one's
chapter two is called the theory of
competition
and it says competition as an act of
policy
as states engage in competition or try
to shape the competitions ongoing among
the range of state and non-state
actors involved in areas of interest to
states they develop
policies frame to frame order and apply
resources to this activity marines need
to understand policy
how it's developed and how it relates to
ongoing competition
my little note here just says what are
you doing
this is me making notes to myself what
are you doing
what are you doing where are you at do
you know what your
what competition are you in you know i
had a
it was an early pop it was a pretty
early podcast i don't know which one but
when i started talking about
what game are you playing and and you
can be playing the wrong game
with your life and if you're looking up
and you're like man i'm doing everything
i can but i just
i'm not putting any points on the board
well if you're playing soccer you might
not be putting any points on the board
because there's only one goal
a game or three maybe you should be
playing basketball
where you can score 48 points a game
sure
so with this competition what are you
competing in
and who are you competing against goes
on marines are frequently asked to
provide
input to policymakers as they deliberate
understanding the larger context around
policy decisions helps marines
determine the broader intent beside
behind specific decisions
which in turn helps us make sound
supporting plans what does that mean
everyone should know why they're doing
what they're doing
like war marines should think of
competition as serving policy
since we acknowledge competition as an
enduring condition
that's a great that's a great phrase
want to adopt that one
enduring condition it's just ongoing
it's forever
in internal relations then we need to
take
equally and equally long view when it
comes to policy as well
u.s vital interests have remained
relatively stable over time for example
since world war ii they've been framed
in various ways while
consistently calling for the maintenance
of our constitutional values
protection of the american homeland and
people promotion of american prosperity
and the advancement of the american
influence in the world
the contemporary environment will affect
these specifics of policy but these but
the enduring foundation for it consists
of stable
interest such as these so what what the
reason i and again
sometimes i look like oh we can kind of
breeze over this part and then i say no
you can't
because if you if you think about your
life okay you can think about your
business for sure
what is it that your business is trying
to do
like do you think a marine wakes up in
the morning and says okay today i'm
going to maintain or
maintain our constitutional values is he
saying all right i've got to protect the
american homeless people we kind of
we kind of know that one promotion of
american prosperity so there's these
there's these things that are so big
such big strategic goals
that they shape every decision that you
make they should
the advancement of american influence
around the world if a marine goes out
and does something stupid in
name a foreign country goes out and acts
like guns gets drunk and act like an
idiot
has he helped the advancement of
american influence in the world no he
hasn't
he and and that's what he's gonna hear
from his commanding officer
you just made all marines look bad and
you just made america look bad
by getting drunk and getting in a fight
or whatever you did that was stupid
and that marine can't deny that he says
roger sir it was a bad move
if that marine would have been thinking
a little bit more strategic
maybe he would have maintained a little
bit more level head on the beers
you know i had a marine one time i was
on a ship
i was on a ship and look we know we we
know that i love the marine corps i was
on a ship
and when you'd pull in to port
you have to get in line to get off the
ship and sometimes it take an hour or
two hours so what we would do is we'd
work out as soon as we got
as soon as we hit the pier we would work
out this is like
1990 whatever we'd we'd hit the pier
work out and by the time we got done
working out took a shower then you could
just walk right off the ship because all
the marines were already gone
so one time i did that like me and my
buddies we got we hit the pier we start
working out
we get done working out take a shower
it's been an hour and a half we come
walking up to leave
so these guys have been off the ship for
an hour and a half they are carrying a
young marine
back onto the ship just completely
brain dead from alcohol
so got to be careful out there
um but so so so when you look at if you
look at the marine corps has these kind
of broad things that they're saying this
is what we're doing
what do you have in your life what do
you have in your business what do you
have in your business
okay just like that young marine if he's
led well he's gonna say you know what
i the whole marine corps is relying on
me to make america look good
got it that's what a good marine is
gonna say
if you're running a a business
and you've got a cashier i've been using
cashiers a lot because you know why
because they're front line and they're
interacting with people
if you've got a cashier that treats a
customer bad he's making the whole
company look bad if he doesn't know that
okay and then what about your life what
are you trying to do in your life
what are you trying to where are you
trying to go with your life what's the
broad
what's the broad strategic mark that
you're trying to make
do you have one do you have one
and if you don't have one how are you
making decisions
you're making decisions for with no with
no
steering whatsoever without a compass
um so these these are enduring
interests enduring interests
provide marines a potential source of
competitive advantage
adhering to our values when done as part
of a comprehensive strategy can serve to
attract others
and work in harmony harmony with marines
with what marines learned from an early
age values such as
freedom of expression and press freedom
can help
frustrate the plans of some competitors
positive some interests
such as increasing american prosperity
also help attract allies and partners
this is especially true when we can when
we can show how our
interests align with theirs
in that interesting if we can work
together we're going to be better off
we're stronger together we're stronger
together than we are fighting each other
domestic policy politics affects the
policy decisions of
almost all competitors and the resulting
character of all
nearly all competitions
everything you do everything you do
impacts the competitors and the
competition itself
as mentioned in chapter one there are
often multiple centers of power in each
nation and the struggle amongst
them often creates ambiguity in the
minds of outside observers these
struggles
affect internal politics and often drive
or limit
current policy choices this is true in
the united states for example
when we see the deliberations on
national policy among three co-equal
branches the government
in other less open societies domestic
considerations have
major impact on policy even though these
considerations are often
harder for outsiders to understand this
happens in businesses a lot you got
some people with different ideas of how
we're going to get where we're going
sometimes unfortunately even disagree on
where they're going
which is bad and that's something with
all the
political mayhem that we're facing in
america right now
i guess maybe mayhem's well with what
we're facing right now we'll just call
it we won't we won't we won't put
a we won't put we want to sign a a word
to it because different people assign it
different words
we'll say that there's disagreements in
america right now
but
this is what this is this is a democracy
is going to be messy
but you're going to get a better result
in the end so
if you if you have a platoon
where hey i'm going to take input from
the troops and they're going to let me
know and sometimes they're going to
argue with me about some stuff or not
argue but we're going to disagree about
some things now if it turns into an
argument we start fighting that's bad
but for for my point man to say hey
jocko i don't think that's a good route
to get into the target and me to say
well why not and for us to have a
discussion about that's a totally
positive thing and we're gonna come to a
better conclusion that's what's supposed
to happen in democracy
we have a discussion but we're both
trying to get to the target
my point man wants to get there i want
to get there in america we got
what are we trying to do we've got to
hope that we are aligned enough that we
say
oh we want our economy to get better
okay can anyone does anyone disagree
with that
all right maybe we disagree on how we
get there but at least we have this one
thing
that we know we're moving towards and
you can say that a bunch do we want
there to be poverty in the country
is there anyone that says yeah what i
really think we need in america is more
poverty no no one's saying that
there's not one person that's saying we
need more poverty in america
so no matter who you are you're saying
yep you know what we don't want poverty
we want less poverty
great now you might think we get there
one way someone else thinks you get
there another way okay
let's figure out what those things are
and then we can discuss how we get there
but it's okay
if we disagree because we're just trying
to find the best solution
and when dave's solution is different to
me than me than how we
to how we get to the target and he's the
point man and i say
shut up we're going my way and he goes
no we're not that stupid and all of a
sudden we're in a fist fight our platoon
is falling apart
so what we do is we listen to each other
and we look for the best possible
solution
and maybe you know as i always try and
just agree with the other person
what does that mean does that mean i
just always bow down and say oh you know
what dave yeah
yep i can't make any decisions so we're
going with the dave says no
because dave wants to go one way that i
think is gonna gonna take an extra 15
minutes
the route that dave chooses as the point
man is going to take an extra 15 minutes
so you know what we're not doing it that
way we have a seven hour patrol uh my
way is gonna take seven hours dave's way
is gonna take seven hours and fifteen
minutes
we're doing it my way no actually dave
you know what
your way sounds great why because i
already i just i just in that moment
i saved 30 minutes of you and i arguing
about it
and now we can focus on something more
important and by the way we're still
getting to the target
and by the way there's so many unknowns
on that route
that i don't know and you don't know and
no one can know and so i'm actually
arguing about something that i have no
idea
where are the land mines where is the
what is the actual terrain like what
how tall is that little cliff that i see
is that something we can get up or do we
need to bring ropes and also it takes
45 minutes just to get up that little
thing we got to carry extra gear i don't
know any of that
so guess what am i going to argue with
you for 15 minutes of difference no
sounds good dave so why don't i have to
why can i let dave do whatever
why can i almost always say i'm gonna go
with someone else's plan
because i worked with dave for long
enough and by the way
i actually taught dave land navigation
so when dave comes to me and he says hey
here's how i think we should go there's
a 98
chance that it's pretty freaking close
to what i would do in the first place
and by the way either way we still get
to the target which is where we're going
back to the book for united states
marines
understanding current current policy
relies in part on understanding the
interplay
between domestic domestic politics and
our enduring
vital national interests shouldn't
everyone just kind of have
enduring vital interests for their
family for their business
for their life should we all have those
things yes we should
as a nation yes we should aspects of
domestic politics like
the election cycle and contemporary
societal issues affect current policy
these aspects are typically felt by
marines through such things resourcing
decisions guidance on the
composition of the force and specific
direction to focus
particular national interests or
particular
competitors you should know the story
about what's going on
that whole thing right there hey
corporal smith
that just heard me read that that said
hey bro i
i'm not i'm not i'm not tracking what
this means is
you need to uh know let's just just
understand what's happening in the world
and understand that what's happening in
the world is gonna sort of guide what
the marine corps is doing
international competition particularly
among nations plays out over a long
timeline oh what timeline is that life
pursuing the goals put forth by the
constitution and its amendments has been
an enduring vital interest to the united
states since the day became effective in
1789 this contrasts with our desire to
bring
war to a conclusion as quickly as
possible
marines need to understand this
distinction
competitive advantage advantages
is relative to a competitor when one
actor is able to do something
better than its rival or rivals check we
get that
what's that uh corporal
terminal lance that's so that's we
should be using terminal ants
that guy's legit uh terminal lance is a
he's a cartoon and he's oh it's actually
a whole book too
terminal ants props
a business enjoys it's interesting here
we go back to business a business enjoys
competitive advantage when it can sell a
product at a lower price than other
businesses assuming other factors like
quality stay the same
nations also have relative competitive
advantages also referred to
as comparative advantages historically
the innovative culture in the united
states helped bring it new goods and
services
to the international marketplace faster
than others the cost of labor in some
countries is lower than others which
makes them more attractive for
labor-intensive manufacturing businesses
it follows then that we must understand
our potential rivals
if we are to develop and maintain a
competitive advantage against them
gee we must understand our potential
rivals
sun tzu art of war know who you're
fighting the united states has many
competitive advantage oh by the way
obviously this is something that we are
doing all the time at origin
right where there's we're competing
against
nations that make the same basic product
that we make but they're doing it with
slave labor
or they're doing it with someone that's
getting paid you know in in horrible
working conditions
and so we've had to find ways and we
continue to find ways that we can
compete with them
and not only are we competitive we're
better because our product ends up
better
and because we're here now now you get
into shipping
and what does it cost to ship things
from overseas
what does that do to the what does that
do to the whole picture
so we're we're figuring out and we have
figured out
how we have a competitive advantage even
though we take care of our workers
which we actually also feel is a
competitive advantage taking care of
your people
is a competitive advantage because now
your people care about the product that
they're making
they want to do a good job
not not slaving in a sweatshop
instead of looking instead of looking at
slave labor
as an advantage i look at it as a
disadvantage
we've got the advantage because we have
a better workforce who
who care about the company
the united states has many competitive
advantages in international competition
the world's largest economy and an
international financial system that uses
the dollar to make transactions are
strong
economic advantages yes the enduring u.s
interest in freedom of navigation on the
seas
attracts many partners because free
navigation reduces the overall cost of
trading between nations
the u.s higher education system attracts
students from all over the world the
list goes on and on
but these illustrations show that we
should look for a nation's competitive
advantages
among its enduring qualities such as
values interest and culture
and this is what you need to do so how
does this tie into everybody
what about your business
what about your business how how do you
have the culture and do you have the
values inside your business that are
actually competitive advantages
do you have that if you don't have that
if you don't have values if you don't
have a culture that's a competitive
advantage you're wrong
the competitive advantages in the
military component
dime are naturally of great interest
to marines since world war ii the united
states
made the use of several military
advantages
such as the joint forces of ability to
project and sustain
power globally its skill at operating
across domains and its expertise and
precision
targeting and strike the us military's
principled professionalism
can also present distinct advantages for
example when is properly
contrasted with competitors seeking to
extend authoritarian government without
regard for rule of law or protection of
civilians
so that's a huge advantage that we have
is that we have military professionals
and that's what they do and it's also an
advantage as far as i'm concerned that
we have
reservists that come and serve in iraq
come and serve in afghanistan that go
for the weekend and
see how the military is doing and take
their civilian expertise
into the into the reserve unit or the
national guard unit for the weekend
we have both those and there's
advantages to both of those
talking about that i i think it was the
guadalcanal
recent podcast we're talking about how
some of the reservists were the people
that said hey that's a dumb idea we
don't want to do that
some of them because they hadn't been
indoctrinated as fully
as somebody that had been you know uh an
infantry officer
for 18 years and he's looking at the
problem going hey i know how to solve
this problem
in the book i know what to do and some
reservist is like hey bro
i hunt in tennessee and that doesn't
make any sense
so we like we use this as a competitive
advantage
i'm just thinking this this whole time
about the connection between these
these military examples and i'm going
through my head things that i remember
as a marine
and how closely connected they are to
just everybody's
everybody's life in both business and in
life just the connections to
your family has you have long-range
plans for your family
you have these strategic long-range
plans for family this is really no
different than i think they call the
the the enduring values of the country
that you need to keep in mind
that might actually change or
influence the smaller things that you do
yeah and and that's something i've been
hitting on a lot the fact that
culture is the ultimate form of
decentralized command culture is the
ultimate form of decentralized command
where now
we have a cashier that knows how to
treat a client
and knows how to treat a customer
because understand the culture of the
company now we have a marine
that can be out in town can see a
situation unfolding
and knows what decision to make just
based on the culture of the marine corps
of the seal teams of the army of the
82nd airborne of the 101st airborne
division if you have that culture
correct
that soldier that marine that cashier
that frontline sales person
they know what decision to make just
based on the culture that you have
inside the organization totally
and that's a two-way street too because
i if i'm running
uh you know a grocery store and i've got
a cashier i'm not going to spend all day
every day just talking to that cashier
about long-range strategic things for
the company
i actually need that person up there
ringing up customers as they're coming
through
but if i don't if i as as the ceo of
that grocery chain or the ceo or
of that company don't think that that
cashier
can't make a strategic a tactical
decision has massive strategic
implications and i lose sight of the
fact that they actually do
at certain intervals need to understand
how what they do affects the big picture
then i'm actually set myself up for
failure any marine that's ever been to
okana
okinawa knows that when the marine goes
out in town steals a car and runs into a
fire hydrant
that marine doesn't just get in trouble
for stealing a car that is an
international incident that undermines
the relationship between two countries
and it happens all the time and if you
don't think your young folks that are
doing these very tactical things
don't have to have some connection to
the big picture enough to guide
their day-to-day decisions you are
setting yourself up for long-term
failure
and that that works both ways that
cashier has to know hey
i've got to treat this customer with
some respect because if i don't
it's going to go on yelp it's going to
go on youtube it's going to go on
instagram
or whatever that might be and i could
take down the whole company if i'm not
careful
you don't want to create paranoia but
they have to understand those those
small
appearing to be small tactical things
can actually influence
the entire organization and they have to
be able to make that connection
if you are in a situation like that and
you're employing
front-line troops to carry out these
sort of tactical day-to-day things it's
pretty easy
to end up in the in the job market
the people that you're hiring the human
capital that you have available to you
it's pretty easy for them to be hey
actually uh
dave ceo dave burke um i actually don't
really care about the company that much
and uh if you fire me tomorrow i'll go
get another minimum job
minimum wage job somewhere else and i
don't really care and so you sitting
here telling me about how we can have a
strategic loss
at your company because i don't treat a
client right
whatever right so what do you do then
and what you have to do is you have to
you have to then
you have to then explain to people that
when that they have strategic
goals in their life that they need to
have some kind of a path that they're
going on
that hey listen listen echo charles
i know you don't really care about
working here that's fine i get it
listen at a minimum if you do a good job
here
you work here for six months you work
here for 10 12 months i don't know how
long you're gonna work
here for when you leave i can give you a
recommendation that'll get you a better
job somewhere
that'll put you on a better path and
that that's all i want look i
know you don't necessarily care about my
company here you don't like flipping
burgers
i get it but guess what when you get
done flipping burgers here
you can go get a job doing something
that's a little bit better
so i don't this isn't just about me and
the company here
jocko's burgers look i i'm going to be
selling burgers for a long time that's
what i do
i love burgers i know this isn't your
life goal
guess what what is your life goal where
is it where are you at
because i can promise you this if you
take care of me here some point you're
going to leave i expect that you got a
lot of potential
when you leave here i want to leave i
want you to leave on the best foot
possible
set up for a long-term better situation
i don't want you flipping burgers
forever
but if you flip burgers well that's the
path to not flipping burgers
which is really interesting one time i
said there was a
person that talked about uh do i really
need to learn jujitsu
if i don't like to fight and i said that
you actually should learn jujitsu more
than anybody else if you don't like to
fight
echo if you don't like flipping burgers
you more than anyone else should say you
know what i'm going to do i'm going to
be the best burger flipper
that i can be because that's going to
allow me
to step up into the next round because
if you can't flip burgers
bro how can i expect you to do anything
else you're definitely not stepping up
the salad bar
and if you can't handle salad bar you
know you're not going to be
the day day opener right and if you
can't be the day opener you're not going
to be the general manager if you're not
the
well do you knock me the store manager
then the general right you see where
this goes
and by the way if you don't want to get
in the restaurant business that's fine
too when you go to work at a
at a at a mechanics shop you want to you
want to be an automotive mechanic
and that's where you want to go what do
they what do i what do i tell them when
they call here to say
could echo charles flip burgers
effectively and efficiently and reliably
and i have to say
no he couldn't he was late
on a regular basis or whatever what if i
say hey you know what echoes
he was totally reliable good to go great
attitude
yeah if you if you looking to hire
somebody that's going to be able to
be a a real bonus inside your
organization
echo charles the guy that's what i want
to do for you
but you got it at least you gotta do a
little something for me too
so if you're running if you're working
with that those those kind of entry
level positions
sure show them the strategic for the
company for the business but also show
them strategically because
look kids don't get that these days
i but never mind these days i didn't you
know what you know why i ended up doing
okay in life is because i joined the
navy and they were like do this and i
said roger
i wanted to be a good seal just that
that enough that guidance that that goal
was enough for me to like keep me out of
trouble keep me from being
a total idiot i was a partial idiot
plenty of times kept me out of
being a total idiot so when you have the
opportunity
to show somebody show a younger person
hey what you're doing right now is
connected to the future you might want
to think about it
here's what is your future oh
okay well you want to be whatever you
want to be
first step is flipping burgers and
that's okay flip them good
don't burn them keep them keep them
together
note that these competitive advantages
exist across the
competition continuum and not only in
the time of war we conduct exercises in
part to demonstrate that the united
states has a military capability it
could use
if necessary the existence of these
capabilities can impose
cost on a potential rival because the
rival
may need to expand resources if they
want to overcome or negate
a u.s competitive advantage as the rival
pursues their goals so you're
you're making other people pay
another little little plug for the
marine corps
hey you gotta have us you gotta have us
and you gotta have a swell train and you
gotta have us well
prepared for battle because that makes
everyone else it imposes a cost on
everybody else which is a positive thing
rate court needs more exercises yes
when viewed from this perspective we
gain an insight of into how
a military competitive advantage can
help us compete with a rival
also note that it needs to be a
conscious decision on when
and how to reveal our most sensitive
competitive advantages
at a minimum we should leverage such
revelations for advantage
in the information element of power
other capabilities might be
cloaked in secrecy until they're
actually needed to be used so there you
go
awesome right don't just reveal
the special move that you have to kick
someone's ass yeah man
we're celebrating i think at least i am
just this is the anniversary of
of the kickoff of desert storm just i
think it was
well when recruiting it's called january
17th 1991 that was the kickoff of
desert storm and you know i was kind of
a kid wanting to be a pilot and
that was the the big reveal for us on
that one that people don't understand
was
is the stealth fighter and all of a
sudden like there's this big
aaa and anti-aircraft system and it's
going to be the robot most robust
air defense system ever and night zero
you know in iraq and all of a sudden
things just start blowing up in baghdad
and nobody has any idea why they're just
sitting there watching
things blow up there's nothing on radar
there's nothing out there as far as they
know
except they can hear airplanes flying
overhead because the jet engines are
making sound and then things are just
blowing up
and we're basically told the world oh by
the way
we hated to have to do this but if
you're wondering
this is what we can do you might wanna
and that that's 30 years ago
our competitors are just just now i
think the amount of time and money
invested in them trying to build stealth
technology
which has been a huge race and a big
competition we showed that to the world
on day zero of the war and as a pilot
obviously we think about that too is the
competitive advantage makes other people
go well
maybe it's just not worth going to war
with them maybe this just isn't worth it
maybe this investment we're making is
not worth it because the outcome they
can do things we didn't know exist
so the revelation of that when carefully
placed in time well
can can be a huge advantage yeah not to
mention they had
no time to adapt to it because if we
would have told them they would have
figured out some methodology or at least
attempted to figure out a more accurate
radar or some kind of a defense system
that could
spot these aircraft overhead yeah that's
a great example of
how you do it it happens in jiu-jitsu
too like if you have that move
that you're pretty good at and you go
for it
it's not a surprise anymore i'm not
saying you're not going to get it
but it's not a surprise and now the
person's expecting it to come
so you want if you're going to do it you
might want to hang on to it just for
you know a little bit deeper into that
role let that person be breathing hard
let the o2 start to lack
all types of competitive advantages can
atrophy however
they all need appropriate practice
exercising and improving if they are to
remain
advantages in the dynamic environment of
international competition
this you can't take you can't rest on
your laurels ever
you can't rest on your loyals ever
competitors
as systems competitors are complex
adaptive systems
again so this this
competitors are complex adaptive systems
i guess we kind of need to say it
right we need to make it clear and then
but it does make it even more clear
meaning
they have many parts and these parts
interact with each other in non-linear
often unpredictable ways
consider iran's national security
decision making structure
to some outside observers it may appear
to function as a strictly
hierarchical organization with all
important decisions being made
by the supreme leader and president at
the top of the pyramid however the
reason story is much more complex
much of the supreme leader's authority
comes from informal relationships he has
with talk
top commanders in the national security
infrastructure
and through the presence of his clerical
representatives in military
organizations
even though the president is the
chairman of the supreme council for
national security
his power ebbs and flows because the
supreme leader is the commander-in-chief
and may bypass
the president through his informal
relationships
so even in that
like they said very strict what appears
to be a strict hierarchy
it's all over the place guess what's
more important
relationships relationships are more
important than the chain of command
even in an autocratic country like iran
the military structure itself can act in
unpredictable ways especially the
islamic revolutionary guards
uh they've developed significant and
separate political power based on
its financial resources because it
controls many businesses
in almost every sector of the iranian
economy each of these power centers
among others jockeys for power inside
iran
working to advance their own internal or
domestic interests
so it's complicated
it's complicated and you know what's
crazy when you see like video you ever
seen videos of in our pictures in iran
and like 19
whatever 1973 it's totally westernized
totally it looks
just like everything's good to go
skipping forward a little bit developing
a model of how a competitor's system
fits together helps identify their
competitive strengths and weaknesses
at a basic level each of these systems
consists of people
ideas and things
the people make the system work they
also analyze its performance over time
because they are also responsible for
sustaining or
improving the system's competitive
advantages
the ideas of the system are found in the
goals it pursues
and in concepts it processes it and
processes it uses to operate in the
world
mao famously stated politics is war
without bloodshed while war is politics
with bloodshed
this quote suggests a mindset that blurs
the lines between peace and war
the mindset this idea creates may give a
competitor an advantage in operating
near the threshold of violence so that's
that statement from mao is sort of uh
the same thing that this whole
there's a continuum right you got
politics which is just war without blood
and then at some point you turn it into
war now we got politics with bloodshed
but i'm going to dig into this one a
little bit ideally there are things then
added or created to support the people
and the ideas within the system so
so we're talking about people ideas and
things
with this in mind
uh within the system helping it achieve
its goals with this in mind we can look
at a competitor's system and create a
model of how it fits together where it
is strong
and where it is vulnerable
finally after creating this model
marines must remain discipline
in its use models are useful but
imperfect
they are theories about the systemic
structure of arrival
we need to remain alert for
opportunities to improve our models
as we learn more about how real how our
competitors operate in the real world
now this is this is the the thing that i
so so they talk about this
sim um people ideas and things like
that's sort of
what a competitor's system is
and i added some well um this is up for
debate
but i'll throw it out there for you
people ideas and things that's sort of
what you judge
how your competitor is going to operate
i i
think perhaps there is possibly one more
that needs to be added
and it may be covered by people and it
may be covered by ideas and it
not things but a little bit that is that
is the idea of
execution or taking action
so you can have people you can have
ideas and you can have things
but if you can't execute then
you're you're dead in the water now
you could say that it's people that
needs to make things execute so okay i
get that
but i just felt the need to kind of call
that out
because when i look at a competitor
i think about yes they got these people
yes they got there they got this team
they've got these ideas okay
i get they've got some competitive
advantages there or disadvantages
and they've got things they gotta
they've got things
but all three of those things without
execution to me i'm not even worried
about you
i'm not even worried about you if you
can't execute so
i don't know am i am i reaching to am i
not giving enough credit to people
possibly yeah i mean i i i guess that
you could dig into deeper what they mean
by that
but when you said it the first thing
that went into my mind
works in the opposite direction too is
that hey they might not have the best
well most well-trained people uh and
maybe their tools are kind of outdated
and their systems aren't so great
because they're antiquated and maybe
they don't have big budgets but if these
people have been
executing and what brought me to is how
many times you've said on this podcast
is who we were fighting in iraq who we
were fighting against al qaeda they
their
things their things were garbage on
paper
compared to ours garbage they were rusty
they were all they
and and there are people and i don't
mean it like the they're people like
something
other people but they didn't have the
training we had they didn't have the
resources they had their people weren't
invested in the way that we invested in
our people
but you know what they had been doing
they'd been executing
for a really long time so that piece
and maybe somebody could say well that's
what people is and
might be missing that but i'm thinking
of people like i know
what american marines and soldiers i
know what those people are
and it's really easy to look across and
go those people those people
and just dismiss what they are but those
people had been
executing and they were really good as a
result and offset
where we thought we had this big
advantage look at our gear look at our
training
on paper it should have been a it should
have been a one-sided affair if you
measured it with those things and what
they weren't measuring was
the the value of the i think what you're
saying is the execution
yeah and even what you just said like um
if you take a group of marines
or you take a group of soldiers
and they have training and it's all good
but if look if they don't execute and
and you could say well a marine is going
to execute we know that's actually not
true
it's it's a good ideal we could say a
soldier is going to a soldier with a
with a platoon leader
is gonna execute not necessarily true
so to me it's all it's almost like a
fourth thing that does make sense in
there
yeah i actually thought that the third
one was going to be the execution
people things and people people ideas
ideas and execution yeah that what so
it's almost like in listening to you
guys and you said a good thing you said
um
dave said on paper because like that's
kind of really what that whole thing
kind of seems like it is because
okay so you got people um ideas
and things but people in ideas is it's
almost like people
is what you can do and then execution is
what you will do
so the so again on paper where you have
this capability
you have this many people with this
capability
with these tools and what they can do
with these tools and then
but then just like i said it doesn't
mean that they're gonna do
yeah it you know like just you guys say
default aggressive
it's like that's that that third kind of
thing
that you have to implement to create
this execution
you ever seen an mma fight that was
about to happen
and on paper yeah that got fighter a
should destroy fighter b and what what
what is the problem when he loses
the problem as he does next execute yeah
the the good and not to go too deep into
the mma thing so remember certain uh
cowboy cerrone and
conor mcgregor right so yeah like
cerrone is an executor guy
he executes he executes but then conor
is like a cerebral guy like he'll play
up stuff
before the fight as well to kind of
create that that third
man in the ring and that third man in
the ring in this case was
to get in the way of execution and
there's like a video on it
that theorizes this where conor mcgregor
was
usually he's talking trash to the guy
telling him basically how much
like junker of a fighter then then he is
or whatever but it was the opposite this
time
it was like he was saying oh man i
respect him and he was friendly
it was really friendly actually so it
theoretically created this mindset
on donald cerrone's in his mind that
it's like oh that
and it kind of took away from his
execution instinct
you know so he was like oh it's like oh
it's not as we're kind of bros
frozen away you know it's like super
respectful fight and then you see conor
how he came out in the fight
all crazy and it's almost like he almost
in a weird way surprised him with how
hard he was executing on a guy who
usually executes but that element didn't
seem to be there as much
you know so it's like man that execution
part of it
bro that's a huge huge deal yeah
and just um props to cowboy props to
connor
cowboy dude he he's got some
and he does eight million other things
yeah um i i wrote something down
as you were getting to the you know
connecting those two paragraphs
and it's it's really interesting to hear
hear the conversations that you just had
and
that adding that additional piece i
wrote down in my margin here
you don't know and so this model this
thing this we create and
and the military does this all that we
create models for everything and we're
like hey i'm going to run a thousand
simulations against my machine and that
we do models for everything we create
this and it was saying hey
don't rely on that model that's even
more evidence the
the the you don't know we can create a
model that can be useful for what
competition's gonna be like what we
think the economy is gonna look like and
we can look at history we can create a
whole bunch of things
that help us make decisions but at the
end of all that you don't
know you don't know and so if you don't
know
how useful is it getting back to the
first things how useful is it to dig in
on your way of doing it
if you really don't know and that's
really what this is saying even i could
say jocko
i've run the numbers i've done this
analysis i've compared to these last
three
a row outside these different i could
give you a thousand reasons why this is
the answer and at the end i should say
but i don't but i still don't know
because you don't know and that's really
part of what this is saying too and the
piece in there when you talk about the
implementation
that's where the execution where it's
all going to happen
so not knowing and acknowledging you
don't know
is also a really powerful thing as
you're building this framework in your
mind how things are going to be
yeah it also that introduces the idea of
i know what you think is going to happen
and i'm not going to allow that to occur
which is
you know what game you think if i can
convince you that all right dave
you and i are going to stand up and you
just see this is like the the
the most lame example but you know
someone that's like oh you know some
wrestler that's like no way i'm gonna
i'm gonna knock him out i'm gonna knock
him out i'm gonna knock him out and he's
trying to convince the other person that
like we're gonna stand and fight so you
don't have to worry about your ground
game or whatever
and then he goes out and takes him down
and does what he's gonna do
it's what game are you gonna play like
i'm going to
get you out of your game uh
that's what i'm going to do take away
your competitiveness yeah actually uh
jeremy stevens against pettis anthony
pettis
and you know anthony pettis is a striker
primarily
and i i was cornering jeremy on that
fight
and jeremy's got you know fists
of lead and he knocks people out
and he he might not be the most
technical striker i'm not saying he's
not technical he's not
i would say he's not as technical as
anthony pettis was at that time
and so we're going into the fight jeremy
definitely going into the fight thinking
hey it's you know cool i'm gonna stand
up i know i can take a punch and i'm
gonna
connect at some point with pettis's chin
and i'm gonna win
what did pettis do came out took him
down
and it was a surprise surprise to me
surprise to jeremy
and that's the way it went but he he
changed he did what we didn't expect him
to do which is just a
brilliant move right so all the things
that you think you know
don't happen had another fighter was
like hey aren't you going to work
ground game and he's like i can't i'm
not going to get taken down by this guy
and i said man you better at least you
know work to get up off your back i'm
not going to get taken down
he's not good enough of a wrestler to
take me down
he's a striker okay cool what happened
this this is after the lessons learned
right the lessons learned from jeremy's
you better be ready for whatever you
better train to fight
because you can't predict what the enemy
is what you're saying dave i can't
predict what the enemy is going to do
can't predict it i don't know what the
enemy's gonna do i might think one thing
but i can't that doesn't mean i can blow
off every other possibility
at all what i need to do is be prepared
to fight
you know the closest thing that they say
in this is um
uh performance they kind of i'm trying
i've i like dug through this like where
am i missing it maybe they are talking
about execution on us don't see it like
the closest i think they have is they
say
analyze you know the the opponent's
performance over time
so you're sort of talking about
execution maybe he doesn't really do it
but i think maybe an additional item to
assess
your opponent is necessary and that is
people
ideas things and execution we also look
at our own
our own system to increase our
competitive advantages or create new
ones
for example do the people
in our system have their necessary
skills and aptitudes required to sustain
our competitive advantages
do they have the skills to build new
ones at a national level
does the target population for our
recruiting efforts have the right
education in a similar way can we look
at our ideas
do our operating concepts give us an
advantage
and things do does any of our equipment
provide over match
to evaluate our competitiveness of the
system again
to me we can check those we can check
the ideas we can check the things we can
check the people
i better check the execution because
none of this stuff matters without
execution
it's not always true that the
organization with the newest or most
equipment wins the competition
quote dave burke sometimes decided is
able to combine adequate material with
innovative new ideas becomes the winner
from this analysis we can then increase
our existing advantages or create new
ones
as deemed necessary
means in competition as similarly
described in warfighting the highest
level of competition involves the use of
all the elements of power marines are
primarily concerned with the military
aspects of competition but we must
not consider it an isolation from the
other elements of national power
war fighting states quote the use of
military force may take any number of
forms
from the mere deployment of forces as a
demonstration of resolve to the
enforcement of a negotiated truth
truce to general warfare with
sophisticated weaponry
end quote here we see the alignment
between our warfighting and competition
doctrines
start to emerge so the whole point of
this thing
in war we impose our will on our
adversary
their cooperation is not required
going back into influence and leadership
right
in competition we make use of military
force to attract
or coerce when using attraction we use
incentives
talking earlier about the carrot we use
incentives to induce a rival or other
political actor
to adopt a position favorable to us or
otherwise allow us to reach our goals
and you know what
sometimes when i'm talking about
leadership i talk about efficiency and
sometimes people think the most
efficient thing for me to do is say
dave you need to use this route to get
to the target
and people think that's the most
efficient hey and it's really hard to
see past that
because clearly if i have to say you
know hey dave well how do you want to do
it and we have to have a discussion
about it it takes us
another seven minutes before i finally
comply with actually what you want to do
and that seems a lot less efficient yeah
but the efficiency comes out tenfold
in the field and in the ex in the
execution
let's think about the execution
it's because as a leader you have to
recognize that what you're doing is not
getting to point a to point b in this
patrol that's not what the actual goal
is
that might be this little mission a
little protected but what you're trying
to do is create a leader that at some
point can go fight a war for you
independently without you being there
in a way that reinforces it so it's this
recognition that's not that's not even
what you're trying to do
and it's the it's that mirage of
this is the best way to get it done i
get in your face i tell you what to do
and look what happened he did it
mission accomplished that is only true
if
the only thing you're actually doing is
getting from point a to point b
which simply is not what you're doing
it's not what you're doing that's
zero percent of the time zero it's not
what you're doing
uh when using coercion we compel a rival
to take an action
in our favor or to stop taking action
that's not in our favor or we make use
of military force to deter a rival from
taking action in the first place
for both compellence and deterrence our
goal is
to use the threat of military force to
achieve our desired outcome
for this to be the case our competitive
advantage must be clear enough to our
rival that it affects the decisions they
make
what's interesting about this is
when i'm your boss dave
i have to remember that when i'm talking
to you
there is the threat of me being able to
fire you
i might not even say a word about it so
i have to kind of consciously
mitigate that threat so that you will
push back against me so that you will
understand that i'm open to your ideas i
have to consciously do that
and so i'm not just compliant yeah yep
cause that threat's there
and sometimes we work with companies
where their people are just scarred
no one will say anything back to the
boss because the last boss would
tyrannical idiot yeah that barked at
everyone and told him what to do and
fired half the organization
and everyone was was scared all the time
to make a move
yeah and that's why by the way that's
why we show up there because the
business is failing because there's
total centralized command and it doesn't
work
um so you've got to use the threat of
military force for this to be the case
our competitive advantage must be clear
enough for a rival
to that it affects their decisions note
that a competitive advantage does not
necessarily equal military superiority a
competitive strength of will
along with non-military tools of policy
are part of the equation too
attraction political actors often use
various forms of attraction to achieve
their goals
to attract someone to to attract someone
is to induce entice or persuade someone
into doing something in a negotiation
it's a reward
or incentive for someone to make a
choice that is favorable to us
we can say that then that attraction is
the counterpoint to coercion
instead of using pressure to help our
goals we use some type of reward instead
okay carrot stick that's what we're
talking about
marines participate in attraction
strategies all the time demonstrating
our professional commitment to our
national values when conducting
bilateral training
in recent years for example as part of
u.s larger u.s attraction strategy
marine
provided marines provided training on
amphibious operations
to an important ally japan check that's
what that's what the marines are doing
all the time
that's what the entire military is doing
that's what we need to continue to do
we get into coercion fast forward a
little bit
political actors often use coercion as a
way to achieve their goals
to coerce someone is to pressure
intimidate or force someone
into doing something or to reach one
goals through the use of pressure threat
or force
there's a big difference in jiu jitsu
between attraction and coercion
right attraction is like you get someone
to defend their neck
so that you can take their arm you can
also
force them to put themselves in a
certain position i guess
but that one's a little bit of a bad
example because you kind of have to
defend your neck
so you're coercing them to get those
hands in position
it does it does this by influencing an
adversary's will
or incentive structure it is a strategy
that often combines the threat of force
and if necessary the limited controlled
use of force with positive
inducements coercion has two forms
compellence and deterrence
compellence is a threat intended to make
an adversary do something
to take a specific action deterrence is
a threat intended to inhibit an
adversary
adversary from taking a particular
action to prevent it from even getting
started
in both cases the target of coercion
must be
cooperate must cooperate because the
target
must decide to comply with the goal of
an actor who is applying
the coercion this cooperation is not
friendly or willing but still must exist
for coercion to be effective not
friendly not willing so
so the just to kind of be clear so the
coercion
positive and negative or the the so
corrosion
like oh okay i'm gonna force this guy or
intimidate this person to
do something versus
not versus but on and then additionally
the other
coercion method is to
intimidate them to not do something yes
okay
yep either compelling them to do
something or you're deterring them from
doing something but
you kind of have to participate in it
right like you gotta
like um like you know i don't know the
security guard or something
like hey don't tell on us or don't
whatever
because we're going to go in this back
door to rob the bank or whatever you
know
right like so if i'm a bank robber i
want to go rob the bank
i know the security guard i'm going to
say hey i'm going to we're going to rob
your bank
don't stop us or else we're going to
kill you or whatever okay yes that's
coercion
yeah from to force him to not do
something right but he
but the point here is that he has to he
has to be willing to do it
right right you're not just for you
could you could tape his head up where
he can't even talk or
move now it doesn't matter whether he's
willing or not he's not doing it
right but i'm saying remove that ability
before the bank robbery it's like
in the planning process you know maybe
the bank not bankrupt but the the
security guard is my neighbor
or something and then i'm gonna be like
hey we're gonna rob the bank
on your shift mm-hmm if so you can't
call the cops
you know or you can't sound the alarm or
whatever we'll kill you or we'll kill
you or whatever coercion
yeah yeah it's also a bad plan yeah i
would think so
but now he's gonna tell on everybody
before it happens
not if i chores him correctly you see
him saying you better have like his
child in
the trunk of your car okay forever
probably it's not that planned yeah
you're right you're right the idea of
using coercion in a competition can be
misleading if we do not
identify the assumptions that support
its use
it's often assumed that a stronger
nation can naturally coerce a weaker one
into doing what it wants however this
assumption may not be true if the weaker
nation is willing to absorb
more punishment than the stronger one
can
or will deliver or stay committed to its
goals over a longer period of time this
is
one of the things that we always have to
think about
this is in the vietnam war when we tried
to say
you know what we can kill a hundred and
fifty of
them for every one of us that they kill
and we said that's a win how do we lose
that yeah i'll tell you how you lose it
those 150 mean less to the to the
communist government
than the one does to the american people
in the american government yeah
when your model places the same value on
people for your enemy as it does for
yourself and go
we've run nobody would tolerate this we
would never tolerate this loss i'm like
well they will
and i was thinking the same thing i was
thinking of what when the soviet union
invaded afghanistan
and again how lopsided that appeared but
in terms of the interest on what they
were willing to endure and how long
they're willing to endure it sooner or
later it's like hey
we're not we just we can't do this
anymore yeah we're ordered on here we're
done here
uh it says the next we call this
asim asymmetry of interests in this case
the weaker nation has the more powerful
desire to achieve its interest in the
stronger nation this is
you have to watch out for this so you
have to watch out for that from
as a leader when you're working with a
subordinate
and you start to escalate through the
continuum of influence
and you don't recognize that maybe they
don't care if they get fired
and all you think you know you want more
word out of you and you're going to get
fired and they don't care
the the example as a parent with kids
probably resonates with a lot of folks
because as you know certainly as your
kids get older that threat of violence
becomes so much less use like hey if you
do this i'm gonna
i'm gonna ground you like okay i'll just
sneak out if you sneak out i'm gonna
take your car away cool
and the the willingness for them to just
outlast you on principle alone or the
willingness to endure whatever you are
going to impose on them you have to
calculate in your mind
what they're willing to endure so you
want to hear about some miscalculation
so my uh my son had gotten a little out
of line this is when he was young
and he was in a very austere
i put him into a very austere
environment
to get him to course and coerce him to
understand what he had done wrong and
how we don't do this kind of thing and
it was really strict and it's not and by
the way
it's no fun for you for the parent right
we don't want to be strict we want to
like have fun and it's all good and we
want to buy toys and we want to just but
you
but when you go austere then you're not
doing any of that and it's not fun
so over time as you know he he was
straightening out he's probably like
seven and
eventually you know he had gotten you
know some toys back
and then he had gotten you know his uh
he could use a pillow again in his
bedroom
and uh you know those kind of creature
comfort started coming back
and then you know two three months later
i s he's you know something this little
spark of like
wait a second and and what i called this
because he was young i called this uh
you know i
i have to be strict with you so then i
started being less and less strict he
started getting some of these privileges
back
and then one time he started stepping
out of line a little bit and i said hey
am i going to have to get strict with
you again
and he said something along the lines of
like
i think maybe you should so that i can
be tougher
i'm always like god
i was like i did not i was i didn't want
to be strict with i want to like let's
go back to party time yeah
let's go back to freaking you know
playing with toys and having a good he
says
maybe maybe you should so i can be
tougher and i was
damn it he just won the test of wills he
won
like you can take go ahead you should
actually you actually went one level
deeper like you should it's in my best
yeah it's in my best interest for you to
do that let's do it immediately oh man
so you got to put you got to pay
attention the kids will come at you man
they'll come at you
psychological warfare
information information plays a special
role
in competition narratives play an
important part
because they are what gives meaning to a
set of facts
for example two comp two competitors may
both desire to possess a particular
island
one of them may have a narrative that
explains their claim to the island on
the basis of historical ownership the
other may have a narrative
that says some of the people that
currently use the island and current
possession makes their claim stronger
two narratives compete with each other
to give facts and meanings
i i got a good question on ef online the
other day
i think it was efon it might have been a
client but it was along the lines of hey
how do we develop this culture and my
answer was you need to tell the story of
what's going on and i
and we when we talked about on this
podcast yeah the marine corps
the marine corps tells the story yeah
that's what i was going off on the last
podcast about
about the squad leader makes a
difference that thing is
primed and ready to rock and roll on the
podcast so
the narrative that you tell the
information that you put out there
is just so important demonstrating a
capability
and exercise and then think and then
communicating
so that it affects a competitor's
thinking
is another way marines use information
leaders determine what capabilities to
reveal and when to reveal them as part
of a larger
approach however much is specifically
revealed
publicizing adherence to high standards
in realistic training
can help sustain the marine corps
reputational advantage
and affect the thinking of our nation's
competitors once again
the marine corps with this manual is
increasing their budget
it's it's attraction for the dod is what
it is
marines need to understand the impact of
culture when they use information as a
competitive tool
cultural differences affect how
narratives are interpreted by various
audiences one message might be
understood in one country in a way that
is significantly different from how it
is understood
in another marines must account for this
and focus the narratives
we use so that our target audience
understands our message the way that we
intend
yes know the story
know the story going back to the
unraveling podcast what is your story
know people's stories
the spectrum and styles of competition
the next section
the usual condition of internal
relations is one of competition across
the elements of national power
below the violence threshold we
typically see activities from the
non-military aspects of national power
for example economic competition is seen
as national at the national level
in the struggle for market share in
particular industry
or the effort to negotiate favorable
terms in a trade agreement
escalation on the spectrum we might see
sharper
economic acts like industrial espionage
the theft of inaction
intellectual property use of sanctions
what's interesting about this is
how often do we go to war
right like if you think about all the
interactions that
america has globally for the last 240 50
years
all these interactions all the time are
constantly happening
tariffs and sanctions in town all these
things are happening all the time and
very seldom do we actually pull the
trigger and cross into threshold of
violence
and that's we should do that as
as as infrequently as possible obviously
and you should assess your own
leadership in the same spectrum
how often do i have to use direct
leadership it should be
extremely infrequently
repetitive actions can also move the
line up or down over time this is about
the this is about how you
how you kind of move up and down these
continuums all the time
gradualism and salami slicing which we
talked about in the last one
competitors use these activities in an
effort to achieve their aims without
provoking a state of war
or even a strong reaction
in addition to competing through
attraction coercion and various forms
illustrated above marines can also
compete by
imposing costs we encourage impose costs
on arrival when we develop a credible
capability and a rival must spend
resources in order to try and counter it
for example the department of defense
has experienced
increasing cyber attacks in the past
decades this has imposed
cost because the department of defense
has to spend time and money
to develop civilian training counter
those attacks
we can also fast-forward we can also
impose costs during war when we first
force the average adversary to divert
resources
from their preferred actions in order to
counter one of our capabilities
and then we get into the threshold of
violence
the threat of violence and violent acts
are competitive tools in international
relations the goal of
posturing is to affect the decision
making of the target to make them
so fearful of the damage they might
receive if the posturing escalates to
violence that they submit
and let the posture achieve their goals
and it places one into a favorable
position should violence
follow just think about that
psychologically if we start to think
about the continuum
of influence or leadership
and you start using direct influence
that's what you're doing you're crossing
over that threshold
where people are forced to submit that's
why you get the equal and opposite
reaction
in some cases the pondering briefly
briefly crosses the threshold and
violence occurs to demonstrate the
resolve of the actor
the brief this brief use of violence
still has the same aim which is to
affect the target's decision
many actors intentionally try to obscure
or confuse
exactly where this threshold lies oh man
that's a good one right
where is that threshold you ever you
ever
uh known someone like that just crazy
eyes like a crazy
eyes person how about how about your bar
you're uh
bouncing at a bar there's some people
where you don't know where the line is
they could
shank you at any moment right and now
you have to contend with them
and there's people that proactively
proactively prop up that image right
yes they do it's a good move
what where you have to you might think
that's a good move as a leader
but what you're really doing is now what
you're doing is you're inducing more
fear
and now people don't know when you're
going to lash out and so now they're on
eggshells and they're afraid to speak up
and speak out
and it's a problem
this has been oh um
they do this to cause enough ambiguity
and hesitation that they can achieve
their aims with little or no
interference this has been true
historically and will likely increase in
the future some rivals use capabilities
like certain cyber and space activities
that have destructive effects but fall
short of some definitions of violence
and effort to obscure whether or not
they would have crossed the threshold
as a push in the envelope in support of
u.s goals marines performed missions on
both sides of the violence threshold
in some cases marines were introduced
into situations
below the violence threshold but then a
political group
performed a violent act against u.s
interests
the disciplined response of the marines
then occurred above the threshold of
violence but the violence was limited
and did not reach
the level of conventional war following
these brief periods of violence the
competition again fell below
the violence threshold in most cases
now we get into decision making
initiative
and response you might just call that
whole thing execution i'm not 100 sure
but you might
marines are taught that decision making
is essential
since all actions are the result of
decisions or of non-decisions
it's so powerful to paint things so
clearly
this is whoever wrote this opener right
here
because you know you how many people
wrote this book dave six
six yeah six
the person that wrote this section gets
a little bonus credit
right marines are taught that decision
making is essential
since all actions are the result of
decisions or of non-decisions
if we lack the will required to make a
decision
then we have willingly surrendered the
initiative to our foe
if we consciously postpone taking action
for some reason
this is also a decision so there you go
boom that's the little section you got
to highlight
terminal lance out there this is what is
what we're talking about
initiative is impo is it is as important
in competition as it is in war
gaining the initiative means our
competitor must react to us
we can gain it by presenting a dilemma
to our competitor
and also by setting the tempo of the
activity taking place
brian stan when he was on his
operational tempo
like he what you know everyone's got
their move
right in jiu jitsu everyone's got their
you know they got that guillotine they
got that kimura
they got that heel hook when brian stan
was on here
i i just remember him just talking about
that operational temple where it's gonna
you know
that's where he's that's what this guy's
talking about
setting the tempo of the activity
marines must assume that potential
competitors
understand initiative as well as we do
thus they will take actions in order to
gain the initiative
many competitors also seek to create
ambiguity about their actions which
leads to a problem
of attribution if we are not certain who
performed a certain action
then we cannot attribute that action to
any particular actor
this often delays our response and slows
our tempo
conversely if we improve understanding
of how of our competitor
we can be primed to attribute their
actions in ways that slow
their tempo instead it's
to know that and to be able to recognize
oh this isn't just
it's not just that i can't figure out
exactly who did this it's that i am now
my ooda loop is slowing down right now
because i think they did it but i can't
be sure
while competition essentially always
exists
its intensity varies over the course of
time
we must also understand that the long
timelines involved in competition mean
decisions and actions sometimes play out
over months or years even decades in
some cases
this often results in opportunistic
behavior as
rivals take advantage of conditions to
achieve their strategic goals
without crossing the violence threshold
or crossing it briefly
and then returning below the threshold
before triggering a war
opportunity is often created when
conditions suddenly change
or temporarily such as when a pandemic
strikes
pandemic strikes which is interesting i
don't know if they wrote this before or
after
i get they probably slid it in there you
think they slid it in there yeah i think
this was drafted
like this last year yeah they slid it in
there such as
this diverts attention and resources
which creates a gap for an alert
competitor to exploit
having no fixed timeline for achieving
goals
plus opportunism also leads to
incrementalism which is the effort to
achieve a goal by adding together a
number of small steps taken on a path
toward it
achieving our goals in compa in
competition
requires action which comes from making
decisions
therefore what marines are taught for
warfighting serves them well here
provided
they also apply judgment in recognizing
how timelines can differ between war
and the rest of the competition
continuum so this
idea of incrementalism is something we
you gotta be on the lookout for
you gotta be on the lookout for that
slow creeping
maneuver that your enemy is making
and at some point you've got to draw the
line what i recommend is
instead of drawing a line you what you
do is you
incrementally respond so
when echo makes a little maneuver
that's a little bit offensive to me i
just don't say well he hasn't really
crossed the line i actually give a
little bit of a check
a little check that's a little check so
from a leadership perspective what does
that mean
it means when dave when dave decides
he's going to spend a little bit too
much money
on the gut on the on the company credit
card
i don't just go well yes i don't really
really cross the line i might say hey
dave
i see i see you've got some uh expenses
here that are
what is this what did you buy just just
check
just checking oh yeah you know i just
needed some
uh some oil for my car okay but
for your car yeah yeah well okay
was that was that for a company trip no
no no hey
i'll change i'll talk to you know we'll
get it straight now okay because you're
trying to incrementally see if you can
start putting real stuff on the company
credit card
no you can't but if i don't
check you if instead i draw a line in
the sand
well now all of a sudden you've
developed a pattern and you've gotten a
habit and you could actually come back
to me and say well i've been doing this
for a while i don't want any of that
so i'm gonna check you am i gonna check
you
with a with a hockey stick across the
face no
i'm gonna give you a little just a
little i'm here
i see what's happening i don't
draw a line in the sand because a lion
in the sand
can be offensive and
why did you break a rule
if you knew the rule was there
if you broke a rule i probably did a bad
job of explaining that
hey man company credit cards we use them
for company business
and what we can't do is we can't have a
bunch of little
charges adding up over time and then we
look up and we
we have lost a bunch of money and spend
it on things that don't
really benefit the company so anything
that you think
you're using for your personal gain or
for your for your personal
life is not allowed
so that's a little bit of a line but i'm
i'm not i'm not smacking you with it
i'm showing it to you and you've got
you have options when you take that
approach you can there's there's a lot
of different things you can do
in there and the the problem with the
line is that
that basically commits you to
to to a response to a course of action
that you it's really
really hard to maneuver away from that
and if you're using the line like hey if
i just draw the line then then jocko's
not going
to cross the line and i use it more as a
tool to keep you from doing it then it's
actually
what i'm really willing to do you have
almost no maneuver space there and you
talk about this all the time you want to
keep as many
options as much maneuverability as you
can and that line takes all that away
from me
and if the line is just a tool to get
you to comply and that person this is
talking about
an adversary this is an alert adversary
looking for ways to commit you
that that limits anything that limits
your options
and certainly i know this about the
marine corps is something we don't want
isn't it a beautiful thing when
um the line is implied with such
strength that i never even said it but
you knew not to cross it how many
how many how many charges have you made
on your company credit card for your
personal gain
the answer is zero right and we're not
doing that here
and not out of fear of compliance either
or or
compliance based on fear but out of a
recognition of why that actually is what
you should be doing
and and you know there are some things
inside here that translate perfectly and
there are some things you actually kind
of have to think about because
they're they're this this publication of
this this manual is
is really in a lot of ways talking about
competitors
and there's the com there's a component
there that that
directly com that aligns well when
you're competing with
you're running a company there's a
competitive company but the connection
to
the liter uh leadership piece to your
people
you got to kind of translate that a
little bit you don't want to go to war
with your people
your goal isn't to set that line to
establish your authority so they comply
you want to avoid that at almost all
costs
but you need your it's the same thing
with my kids do i want my my son
to know that there's a line yes he and
he
knows he almost well it happens but he
doesn't cross that line very often i'm
not
forced to respond in a limited way very
often
but i want him to know that yeah so
let's say there was a street
in front of your house really busy would
you put the line
that your son when he's four years old
would you put the line at the street no
hell no
you'd put the line a little further back
and would you
would you then escalate like hey you
can't go past this
this is this is 20 yards from the road
where you could get killed
that's what we do yeah now even even the
actual line where you're gonna like give
significant punishment because you have
to because you have to
you have to you have to impress upon
the kid like my uh my dog kid dog
my dog i have this at my house if my dog
goes
out off my front porch
he's gonna be on a street where there's
cars right
i gave him hard corrections when he was
a puppy that dog doesn't leave there
he knows what's up he knows that he
can't do it
so that's where the lie and but the line
isn't
it he could go off my porch and go
another 15 yards before he'd actually
get hit
yeah but i don't give him that extra 15
yards i'm like okay here it is don't go
don't go across this line and he's been
trained and he understands it
so that's uh what you got to watch out
for
and your dog might not ever make this
connection but the obvious goal with
your people is that
the recognition is that it's in their
best interest you're trying to help them
and that's that's the piece of like hey
when you're talking about your
adversaries and you even talked a little
bit about coercion
in some way we're actually evil with our
adversary is basically trying to say hey
don't do this this is in your best
interest please don't
do this or hey i'm going to really need
you to do this but
from a leadership standpoint all those
things even those lines that you draw
the ideal situation as you as a leader
is actually what's in their best
interest and
they're pushing against it you might
want to find out why they're pushing
against that
anyway i just think that that connection
of what's in their best interest
and that that line i mean we
you want to be able to maneuver as much
as possible all the time and keep as
many options open
as as possible and so that line should
be
just be real cautious about drawing that
explicitly and if you do
if you can get them to understand why
that's there that's so much more
powerful than it's just hey i'm gonna
i'm gonna hammer you if you hit across
this line
yeah the why is huge
and if they don't understand why then
it's an arbitrary thing that you throw
up there
and look i'm not saying that you
shouldn't have that because if people
you should absolutely have lines where
hey you crossed this line you made an
ethical mistake you did something that's
that's
actively freaking criminal you're done
yeah that's where we're at
just so everybody knows you do something
like that
you're done period end of story there's
no there's not even discussion
so don't do that
getting into the conclusion like war
competition serves
policy but usually does so over longer
spans of time these
long timelines lead us to look for
policies
aims in our enduring national interests
with aspects of these interests
emphasized by current state of domestic
policies
politics again apply that to your
personal life
apply that to your business what are you
trying to do what are your enduring
interests
attraction is important concept in our
theory of competition
it uses incentives and rewards to get
another political actor to act
differently in ways that are aligned
with our interests that's what we're
doing as a leader
we're using attraction we're using
coercion
we're using the stick we're using the
carrot what do we want to use
we want to use we want to use the carrot
as much as possible and you know what we
want them to think they found that
carrot
coercion is another important component
of our theory it takes two forms
compellence
to cause a rival to take action
favorable to our goals
and deterrence to cause a rival to not
take action
that's what you were asking earlier i
think echo i don't know if i gave you
that clear of an answer in war we impose
our will on an enemy
with coercion we need our rivals
cooperation because they must decide to
comply with our wishes
even if their cooperation is unwilling
the existence of the marine corps is a
coercive tool for the nation
if its competitive advantages advantage
is made clear to a rival
competitors act like systems they have
many parts that interact with
each other in complex often
unpredictable ways
this also means competitors have
strengths and weaknesses as competition
unfolds over time
the rival systems can sense
what their competitor is trying to do
and adapt or evolve
in an effort to improve their
competitive advantage it's always
adapting
these will often blend the threat of
violence or the use of violence itself
with other tools to gain an advantage
this constantly shifting mixture can get
confusing which is part of the goal
competitors often intend for this
confusion to help them reach their goals
by causing their rivals
to hesitate
this also helps them gain the initiative
so that they can set the pace
the tempo for the competition
we're two hours deep right now i'm not
even getting that well the chapter three
is next
um you know
something that i i i say
and i know i think you and i uh
discussed this the other day on the
phone dave
the best way to win is when the enemy
doesn't even know they're fighting right
the the what sun tzu was the supreme
what sun tzu said
was the supreme art of war is to subdue
the enemy without fighting
that's what we're trying to do to win
to to influence dave without dave even
knowing that i influenced him
i want to maneuver my ideas into your
head so that you think they're they're
that you're
they're your ideas
i want to preemptively remove your will
to fight before you even think you
should be in a fight
before before you even think you should
be putting up resistance you already are
thinking that you don't want to resist
that's my goal
i want to make you a champion of my
cause as if it were your own cause
that's what we're trying to make happen
and by the way what what makes this easy
er what makes this and actually makes it
easy is when
my cause is your cause because you're
it helps you if i'm over here trying to
convince you to do something that
doesn't help you man it's freaking hard
but when i can align my goals with your
goals and i can give you ownership
that allows that allows
these strategies and tactics
for you to get on board with what i want
you to do
and you don't even know that i'm trying
to make you do it
so it's one of the most important things
about this manual is simply making you
aware that you're competing and you have
to be aware
that you're also influencing all the
time
and you're on that spectrum and you're
you're on that continuum and you're
either
gaining leadership capital or you're
spending it
and if you do it right people are on
board
and the and the deeper part of that is
you are actually propelling
them towards victory for them
if you do it right you're propelling
them towards victory and they are
happy to be moving there and if i'm
trying to get dave to do something
that he's resistant to
and it's going to help him in the long
run it's going to help us in the long
run why is he resistant i need to listen
to him to see what
what his resistance is why is he
resisting
that's what we're doing we're on
a constant continuum
of influence yes we're competing but
we're influencing
as leaders
echo we're also competing obviously sure
we want to stay competitive right in a
multitude of ways
sure we'll say any um
any ways that you can recommend for us
to
maybe maintain or improve our
competitive advantage in the world
what do you think what do you got
advantage big time
first one which i think kind of goes
unnoticed and you do good job
in reminding us from time to time is
what game
are you playing so it isn't that like
kind of one of the questions you used to
always get
like what motivates you right so you
just get that one a lot yeah
and still kind of a question like um
that you kind of got to ask yourself a
lot of the time
like because it kind of seems like okay
so like getting in shape
right for example or being in shape
staying in shape whatever
right like for some for the average
person uh whatever that even means
because i don't know what that
actually even is but to wake up at 4 30
and do and it's not like you're waking
up at 4 30 and doing like a
you know a stretching routine for 10
minutes like right you're kind of going
hard you know but we're going hard
and that's every single day not to say
you're going full speed every single day
yeah but
i'm just saying your routine is like the
average person not going to do that you
know
so you're over here going going hard but
why you know
competitive advantage seeking a
competitive advantage exactly right so
what i'm saying is in your head it's
there you know yeah but i think in like
all of a lot of our heads it's like man
it's not always there like we gotta
kind of get reminded everyone you know
just to confirm
things in the world you know in
discipline equals freedom
field manual i i talk about like how if
you
exercise you'll be sharper right
mentally sharper
and then hearing that chess player the
other day gary kasparov talked about how
if you're in shape it's going to help
you win at chess yeah
i was like keep working out people yeah
keep working out people
that's what you need to do yeah and
actually
and you're kind of always your minds
kind of seems to be anyway always kind
of in that zone where it's like you're
kind of looking for some kind of
advantage or something to add to you
know
your deal or whatever but for the
average person i think some of us don't
do that all the time
because we kind of forget or maybe get
distracted or whatever maybe that's the
same thing but
where that's why people they'll work out
less more things going on
all this stuff right so they forget yeah
yeah you got that
let's face it if you pour all your
efforts
into your job your family
and your physical health are going to
fall be pour
all your efforts into your family your
job and your physical health is gonna
fail
if you pour all your efforts into your
physical health your
job and your family are going to fail
yeah so we have to be balanced
if you let the physical one fall apart
that's going to negatively impact the
other
i actually they all they all impact each
other right they all impact each other
but
let's face it as you pointed out on one
of the earliest of these podcasts the
physical one will help you
across the board in all aspects of the
game
so in a way maybe which game the game
the game straight up
in a way the best way the best strategy
you know instead of pouring everything
you have into your xyz whatever
one thing you align them all and
understand that they're all this
what they call it in business vertically
integrated or
whatever right it's called the path the
path yeah
same thing so look i'm gonna exercise be
capable of do jiu-jitsu i'm gonna um
improve all my applicable skills
so i can be a better whatever those
things are whatever you are you seem to
i think i'd know where you're going with
this
people should get supplements from orgy
is that where you're going with this i
think i think i just saw a little
a little connection getting made yeah
and thank you because because i was
thinking starting to think
like like hey if we're going to make
that connection in a minute maybe two
minutes
i'm down yeah i'm down see that kind of
artistic maneuver
the intellectual sharpness as you bring
it in for the big win and all of a
sudden you're talking about how we're
going to get some supplementation
hype on that okay and when we start
going 12 minutes
okay and we're talking about alignment
and vertical integration this is an
important thing
okay i'm just saying now you did have
one person respond on social media that
they are listening
right now so that person is happy that
you're going
down the path of whatever you're going
down hey look which is fine
oh all right well hey better to be um
over-informed than under-informed
okay so hey look dave i don't know if we
can make that necessarily a blanket
statement
because i think there's people that are
right now questioning
at this moment hey thanks for helping it
along okay you know you're getting your
little bump a little push you do a great
job a little influence a little
influencer
little influence anyway all right cool
we're
here trying to compete stay competitive
improve and maintain our competitive
advantage okay
look we need supplementation see how
quickly that worked
yeah i said kind of set you up like hey
how can we maintain competitiveness you
said boom and you were there i know
manny seems like my idea too there was
no
in my head and man that was like man the
best idea ever came up seeming
seemingly that was a good job yeah
anyway
so i'm taking discipline and discipline
go that's probably why my brain is so
sharp
let me let me say something because even
as you're talking about this people are
thinking
okay what does this all mean here's what
here's here's a bonus thing because we
repeat a lot of the same stuff
right sure we certainly seem to repeat
what are you right now nothing no you
just continue please with your thoughts
you're making notes not using this
indication of something
are we editing stuff please continue are
we editing things
you can edit it out check this out i got
good news
everything that you're about to talk
about
is available with free shipping at
origin maine.com
if you get a subscription so if you want
what do you take every day
all of them uh joint warfare okay super
curl oil vitamin d
discipline in some form every single day
dave what are you on daily cold water
what about what about vitamin d so i
guess
i have to remember i have such a stash
of this that i forget
geez so so i'm i am
i'm almost ashamed to say that but
the only one i don't have a huge stash
of is
cold war i think you said vitamin d
maybe that's what you were
alluding to wait what did i say you said
vitamin d yeah
i i say cold war that one is now
that one is now on regular shipping okay
30 days
so if you go on that if you subscribe
yes
and of course go then you get free
shipping yeah which is
pretty awesome yes sure so if you want
to get any of these items on a regular
basis
which we recommend you do
get subscription get a subscription and
you get free shipping
okay done so let me go down the list
these are all beneficial things maintain
the competitive edge joint warfare for
your joints
don't worry about that stuff you don't
have to worry about your joints anymore
super crew oil same deal
general health other benefits vitamin t3
and
is another one also cold war this is for
immunity and other health benefits
better to have health benefits than
health detriments
facial expression said i don't know what
to say i mean you pulled it off
credit negative credit it was in the you
understand
anyway back to the supplements
discipline
and discipline go so just blend the
powder for your brain for your body
discipline go
brain body just on the go quicker
delivery system
capsules and also the energy drink form
it's a healthy energy drink by the way
if we didn't already know
even though we do that is those are the
facts also milk for extra protein
forming dessert
super delicious tasting protein as a
dessert yeah you could say extra protein
where you just say oh if you want also
want a dessert cool you can get some
milk
get them out while you get the drinks
you get the the ready to drink the cans
at wawa all the wawas by the way they're
in there
and vitamin shop so you can you can get
them there or you can get them at origin
maine.com and if you get a subscription
dang you're in the game there's a little
issue with the wawa scenario
what is it i got a lot of videos of
people just going in there and cleaning
it
out so people will go in there with
coolers yes
go into the shells of wawa and empty
every can so
be warned yeah they're getting after
people are getting accurate
but the great the great thing is uh we
started off in florida
yeah and it was sort of a test run for
wawa
and everyone went after those
when after those discipline goes in wawa
and just
almost uh like less than a month into it
less than a month
into a three-month trial wawa came to us
and said we want you in all the stores
so thank you for for getting after it
and
was going to deliver wall was also in
the game because
they get tagged a lot from people out
there shopping walls and they always get
a good reply awesome yeah
interesting that yeah i saw that with a
guy with the
cooler it was like a bin and he was like
boom and i was like
that's interesting i don't think i've
ever been really that compelled to do
that with it with a
like a drink or whatever i'm saying
under what circumstances would i be
and then i thought back to like maybe
like four days or so before where i
texted belittle with the emergency
scenario because i was only on my last
one this one
here's the thing they'll send it they'll
send it and because usually i don't go
to my last one but what if i'm on my
last one and i'm like wait a second i
can go to huawei and restock you see i'm
saying then you're bringing a cooler so
it makes sense exactly right that's
another good reason because if you're on
a subscription
that day doesn't come that's true that
day does not come and we don't want that
day to come
nope so yes uh you mentioned
origenmate.com that's where you can get
it as well
also on origenmain.com
you can get jiu jitsu stuff gear
keys rash cards that kind of stuff also
shirts and sweats and
cool clothes as well this is all
american-made stuff by the way
big deal yeah huge deal competitive
advantage
yes competitive advantage to have not
slave labor
but awesome people yeah you you
mentioned that
like um slave labor like when you kind
of you know the front end of the slave
labor situation right
you just be like oh yeah we'll just make
it super cheap you know you guys don't
make it and we can sell it for hire
whatever but if someone cares about what
they're doing on every step you know
like manufacturing like okay my job is
to do this and
do this and to do this and i'm going to
just do it but i care about doing it bro
that's way better
like quality wise in every capacity and
sustainable
yeah so yes that is a competitive
advantage what if everyone on your team
cared about what
their job was bro that's how i'm gonna
go ahead and say you just nailed that
sir i agree that that is the case unless
back to how we can all support ourselves
talk about the store it's called jackal
store this is where you can represent
your apparel
while you're on the path maintaining
your advantage
competitively we have shirts and hoodies
and hats
they all say discipline equals freedom
or something along those lines
good good same thing in a way
kind of part of discipline anyway you
understand what i'm saying
um some good stuff on there there's a
t-shirt club it's called the shirt
locker shu thank you to whoever made
that suggestion
yeah that's a good one it was a lot
better than the other name that we had
been using here the thing is to be
honest like the more i think about it
the shirt locker is like it didn't even
matter what the name was before that one
would probably be better because it's
like perfect
that's the perfect name the shirt locker
yep and that is also a subscription
scenario where you can get
different types of shirts
from us a little not hardcore discipline
equals freedom stuff but some fun stuff
it's cool it's a cool little deal so
look into that if that's for you do that
man chocolatestore.com
uh subscribe to this podcast um you can
also join us
on the underground go to jocko
underground.com it's alternative
podcasts
some amplifying information some behind
the scenes
some q a some live stuff
and we're gonna we're gonna actually
record yet another
underground podcast right now about
going into some
other facets of these discussions
and and the reason we're doing that we
don't we we need to have an alternative
platform
uh we don't want to take on sponsors
where we have to
say what they say us
say what they tell us to say and then
also
not say what they tell us not to say
we don't want to do that we definitely
don't want to have anyone
critiquing how certain people on this
podcast
talk about the items that we're
discussing
oh dave you like that i don't know look
at dave look at it look at you all right
it costs 8 18 cents a month uh or you
can if you can't afford eight dollars
and 18 cents a month
by the way this is what supports this
podcast
um too but we we don't want to have the
jocko podcast behind a
a paywall i always say firewall and you
like correcting me
right before i even said it which is
good because i saw you
right my mouth put in the sink is that
that
well a firewall is an actual thing yeah
in like programming or something like
that okay well we just have a we don't
want to put it behind a paywall because
we won't even be able to hear it and so
that's why eight dollars and eighteen
cents a month you if
you can't afford that it's okay email
assistance jockonunderground.com
and we will take care of you we also
have jocko
unraveling podcast we have the grounded
podcast we have the warrior kid podcast
we have a a youtube channel where echo
puts
his legit videos a lot of those most of
the good ones are ones that i'm the
assistant director on
and you'll notice a trend there yeah
hell yeah
the good ones uh psychological warfare
album on itunes if you need a little
help
getting over a little whatever moment
moment
momentary weakness maybe permanent
weakness yeah
maybe you'll be listening to that thing
a lot if you have like permanent
weakness
so you get that on any mp3 i also got
flipsidecanvas.com dakota myers company
got a bunch of books leadership strategy
and tactics field manual
that's ready for you all the answers are
in that book
what do you think dave yes
the the code the evaluations the
protocols we got about
face with i wrote the forward honor to
be able to write that definitely
freedom field manual way the warrior kid
one two three
and four the way the warrior kid field
manual is out mikey and the dragons and
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
we also have a leadership consultancy
called echelon front go to
echelonfront.com for details on that we
have ef online
where we are have courses that you can
take on leadership we have
live interactions there go to
efonline.com
we have the muster in 2021 which is our
leadership conference go to extreme
ownership.com for details we're
making some adjustments on that right
now on when those are going to take
place
ef overwatch executive leadership for
your company go to efoverwatch.com
if you want to help service members
active service members retired service
members if you want to help gold star
families and service members families
at large then you can check out mark
lee's
mom's charity organization mama lee
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org
and if you didn't get enough of my
severe circumlocution
or you need more of echoes befuddled
bulletins or dave's exhaustive
explanations
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on instagram
which obviously echo only refers to as
the gram and on facebook dave is that
david
r burke echo is adequate charles and i
am at jocko willing and thanks to all
the military personnel out there in all
branches of service
in uniform around the world keeping us
out of harm's way
by going into harm's way yourself
and also thanks to police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol
secret service all first responders we
thank you
for the same for going into harm's way
to keep us
out of it and everyone else out there
you are somewhere
on that continuum on the competition
continuum on the leadership continuum on
the
influence continuum it's happening every
moment
of every day
so don't lose track of that and don't
get
beat without knowing you're competing
you are competing
so stay in the game by going out there
and getting
after it until next time
this is dave and echo and jocko